veamos unos ejemplos con exponentes
fraccionarios ya sabemos que si yo tomo
por ejemplo 9 a la potencia un medio
esto es igual a 3 y sabemos eso porque 3
por 3 es igual a 9 esto es equivalente a
tomar la raíz cuadrada de 9 eso es igual
a 3 pero qué pasaría si por ejemplo yo
tomo 9 a la menos un medio hoy como que
dices que a una que hago aquí no me da
miedo pero no te intimide simplemente
respira hondo y date cuenta de ese signo
negativo primero primero que todo ignora
la fracción y ahí tenemos un signo
negativo que lo convierte en un
exponente negativo entonces esto
simplemente es lo mismo a 1 sobre 9 al a
un medio fácil cierto ese signo negativo
es lo que representa 9 a la menos un
medio será igual a 1 sobre 9 a la un
medio pero 9 a un medio es igual a 3
entonces tenemos como resultado final un
tercio y ya terminamos vayamos ahora un
poco lejos
que ya que será igual esto ponle pausa
el vídeo cuando ponga el ejemplo y
inténtalo entonces por ejemplo menos 27
a la menos un tercio a la menos un
tercio jajaja se ve se ve aterrador pero
pero por la pausa inténtalo ya que a que
será igual entonces veamos simplemente
relájate recuerda relájate respira hondo
y deshazte del signo negativo entonces
esto será igual a 1 sobre menos 27
elevado a la un tercio positivo y tal
vez tú digas bueno esto no me está
haciendo la vida más sencilla porque
tengo este menos 27 entonces ok
tranquilo no pasa nada cuando tienes ese
tienes aquí un número negativo elevado a
un exponente fraccionario pero eso
simplemente te está diciendo te está
pidiendo encontrar un número tal que si
lo multiplicas tres veces a él mismo te
da el número menos 27 igual a menos 27
qué número cumple con eso ya sabemos que
3 a la tercera potencia 3
la potencia es igual a tres por tres por
tres y es igual a 27 eso veintisiete
positivo entonces a menos tres a la
tercera potencia que será igual esto es
lo mismo que menos tres x menos tres x
menos tres y menos tres por menos tres
es igual a nueve positivo nueve positivo
por menos tres es igual a menos 27 y
encontramos el número misterioso así que
menos tres por menos tres por menos tres
es igual a menos 27 por lo tanto menos
27 a la un tercio
esta parte es igual a menos 3 entonces
esto 1 sobre menos 27 a la un tercio es
lo mismo que uno sobre menos tres o lo
que es lo mismo menos un tercio y ya
terminamos nos vemos